In today's video, I'll be using the new
Chat GPT work mode to audit and help me
rank a website higher and get more AI
search mentions. So, if you don't know
what Chat GPT work is, it is a new way
to use Chat GPT. It allows you to
connect Chat GPT to your local file. So,
for example, I can connect it to my
local files, I can connect it to my
desktop, I can connect it with different
plugins, Gmail, spreadsheet, so on and
so forth. So, essentially I can tell it
to do anything to read my files on my
desktop and use that information to
create a spreadsheet or to create a
Google Doc and then send out an email
with that information. So, it's
connected to all of your applications
and your local computer. It's very
similar to Claude Cole work, which again
allows you to connect to all of your
native apps and your computer and then
also allows you to create schedule task
on a day-to-day basis. So, in today's
video, we're going to be using our SEO
audit skill. So, if you want to go ahead
and get this skill, just comment Chat
GPT work below and I'll send you over
the skill. So, we went ahead and we put
the skill into Chat GPT and we can see
that the audit is now finished. So, we
got an SEO audit and a keyword search
report for this specific website. We got
a score of 38 out of 100 technical SEO.
We see places of improve- improvements,
the keyword strategy, local SEO reviews
and AI search. And of course, everything
here is going to be specific for you and
actionable items that you can actually
go out and do. So, next what I'm going
to do is I've went ahead and actually
connected our Word Rocket MCP in order
to add Word Rocket onto Chat GPT. You
need to first head over to safety and
login and then you need to turn on
developer mode. So, turn it on and then
you go back over to plugin.
We're going to go to browse plugin.
We're going to click the plus button.
We're going to name it Word Rocket
AI and then for the connector, we're
going to do https
wordrocket
api.com.
And then once you do that, it'll connect
you over to Word Rocket where you can
then sign in. And once you sign in, your
Word Rocket connection will now be set
up with uh ChatGPT. In the report that
we got back from ChatGPT, we saw that
there are some keyword ideas in which we
can write about. So, for example, this
keyword is a Niagara Falls day trip from
Toronto worth it, content format, pages
to create. So, we see that this is a
good article here. And we can
essentially go ahead and send this over
to Word Rocket to generate. I've told it
to generate this article in 3,000 words,
use web search mode with three images,
post it to our website directly,
and use Claude Sonnet 5. So, after a
couple of minutes, and as you can see,
it did use the uh Word Rocket
integration. The article is now posted
onto our site. Let's go ahead and take a
look at it. As you can see, we get a
nice um cover image here. We get the
title, so is Niagara Falls day trip from
Toronto worth it? Quick answer, key
takeaways,
um and then we get the GEO optimized
questions, and we get a nice table here,
list, timings, another image, which
looks really, really good. More GEO
questions here, and our references,
which Niagara options fits you, some
code that needs to be cleaned up. So, as
you can see, ChatGPT work is very, very
useful when it comes to doing your SEO,
when it comes to then connecting it with
other plugins and tools, that's where
you can really um level up the features
and the usability of ChatGPT work. So,
if you guys want to go ahead and get
this free If you guys want to get this
skill, just comment ChatGPT work below
and I'll send it over to you. I
definitely recommend checking it out.
All you need to do is download the
desktop application of chat GPT and then
you'll be able to access chat GPT work.
Thanks you guys and I'll see you in the
next one. Take care.